hello and welcome to the new world
review where we may be at the point of
battle and maybe the loss of a certain
key traumatized character or two
who knows with this show what we do know
is that there are some children with a
lot of learning to do so sit back
relax with biscuits cookie and let's do
a little regrouping because
yeah episode 90 was a very cerebral
episode all about perception of the
world and perception of others
and we can go into each character pretty
easily and quickly and learn a few
things about them so
i'm gonna do a little of that though i
want to say that i am a huge
huge fan of the static that replace the
placement of kilowatt's eye for
many reasons so let's get into it and
i'll come back to it maybe probably
maybe not i can be fickle i'm a fickle
beast like that we started out with gone
and knuckle fighting gone who works on
instinct is being forced to fight that
instinct more than the physical attacks
his decision-making up to now has been
instinctive and immediate and it's sort
of his hallmark in order for him to
think clearly about things
he needs to sit down and sit with them
or at least be knocked out by the
situation possibly metaphorically
knocking the sense into him in the
process
he's all impulse all adrenaline and he's
so attuned to that that it makes sense
that he would immediately realize
what's happening to him when a little mr
mime creepy bank teller turns up to
repossess his men
which is funny i fully understand why he
didn't want to deal with the numbers the
second knuckle started to reel them off
i tried to keep up at first and then
gave up on it entirely
fairly quickly i think i even visually
disconnected by the end because while
i'm
very capable of dealing with numbers i
don't engage in anything
at all for fun that uses numbers that
way i'm happy to explain mechanically
what i'm doing when i work on impulse
because i've had to learn how to break
things down
to explain to people who just don't
understand why i'm doing the things that
i do
or how it bears any relevance to what
i'm
doing but that doesn't mean i want that
in my visual media
if i'd been younger and actually paid
attention i'm fairly sure looking at
those numbers and the interest rates
that became exponential over time would
have been
possibly better money handling training
than i ever received at school
purely because it is animated and
relevant to life but we already knew
halfway in how much gone was taking in
of this explanation and
in fact by episode 90 we knew before he
started to explain it how gone would
react to this explanation and so my only
conclusion for it taking so long to
explain has to be that tagashi wanted us
to feel what glenn felt
anyway now gone has to learn to think
very strategically rather than his
standard mo
of punch it and it goes away and that's
what knuckle was talking about with
god's weaknesses
in a world where it takes time to load
up your attack someone using time
against you becomes a very dangerous
prospect
this isn't dragon ball z this is not a
situation where people stand around and
go
what all that power in a very
vegeta-like way
gone is now in a situation where he has
to learn how to measure his attacks
as well as how and where they land in
absolute terms in the past he would just
use it until it burned out and he
collapsed
the consequences here are very real
because not only are there immediate
consequences there are long-term ones
that mean he won't be able to achieve
his overall
overall goal it was a nice reminder at
the end of the episode that the queen
ant is still eating and her son is due
any day now it was more subtle than
taking us to a puppeted kite and
less subtle than showing us what all
their trainers are up to so
i appreciated that speaking of trainers
knuckles softness with gone has been
notable
throughout the last few episodes and
it's good to see him deciding that gone
is now worthy of his attention
it's an interesting decision from
tagashi to have a real soft personality
who loves animals but is a nan
accountant giving non-consensual loans
to others in order to weaken them
it's a horrifically accurate assessment
of corporations when you think about it
look at this beautiful thing i do with
one hand
now i will attack you with kindness
don't forget to pay all the interest
yeah i'd have learned a lot back in the
90s speaking of learning in this episode
both pre-teens are learning how to
engage in fights in the opposite way
gone has long fought offensively willing
to take a hit if it means he'll get one
in
a solid strategy though i don't think
he's ever thought about it
meanwhile we have our flight risk kilwa
trying to deal with the curse on him to
keep his feet on the ground and stand
for something
one of the things i've been trying to
gauge with this episode is whether the
curse is physical or
magical or purely psychological i wonder
whether it's nen binding him or repeated
trauma from illumi basically and
and now i'm loving the name illumi
because what he's done is potentially
illuminate
the instinctive defensiveness kilowatt
naturally has
even looking at the first frame of the
end credits as i am because i paused to
make a note and ended up just writing
we can see that gone is looking out into
the world while kilwa is looking inside
himself there's a melancholy
a drawn in nature to kill one that i
wonder being someone deeply interested
in identity and personality where the
kiwa has simply been positively
reinforced to behave in protective mode
rather than trained to do so he's not an
extrovert or
hasn't been presented as such that's
definitely gone and he's willing to try
to fight but for his place by gone side
but something stops him
repeatedly and it seems like literally
something i've always been interested in
is kilwa's amazement that gone is asking
the questions he asks it never occurs to
me that kilowatt doesn't ask the
questions because he
can't i assumed that the differences in
personality were to do with differences
in thought pattern
and the fact that kilwa actually does
think about the potential consequences
for his actions
but now i'm wondering whether he holds
the questions in because there are extra
consequences if he voices them
and it's not just that he's deciding to
voice the questions he's afraid to voice
but who he's going to voice it to
he's about to ask someone we know is a
coward the fight between
shoot and kiwa is perfect because
anything we learn about one is
counterbalanced by what we learn of the
other
both are cowards but in the opposite
direction let me explain because i don't
know if that's clear on the one hand
we have kilwa who could very easily kill
shoot
but can't because something in him is
telling him his continued existence is
worth more than the shame or loss of
anything in the world even the most
important thing in the world to him gone
on the other hand we have
shoot who i don't think could beat kilwa
in
any other situation and can only be as
strong as he currently is because of the
condition he's placed on himself
that forces him to be brave and to
remove his ability to empathize
one is trying to disengage with his
brain and focus on his body
the other is trying to disengage with
his body and focus on his brain and
that's
fascinating isn't it and the worst part
is really that if keowa
asks the right question it would force
shoot to engage with his brain and
potentially stop him from being able to
use his net abilities and
i love that conundrum i love not
knowing the outcome of that i love the
possibility
but if kilwa wins this way is it a win
or a loss is he winning because he
managed to make himself vulnerable and
in doing so drop the defensive posture
that protects him or is he losing
because his method of winning is
socially rather than physically driven
and the ants don't care about being
social they just want to kill you
and eat you so those are the thoughts
that run through my mind when i watch
combat like this because ultimately we
have to see each battle as having
intrinsically character developing
concepts or it's just a series of
punches and that's kind of boring after
a while
no matter how they're animated the level
of depth in this show
is phenomenal almost because it can make
me think like this and it's what i enjoy
about it more than anything
let's see how things shake out in
episode 91 episode 91 and this was
another big brain episode
despite all the emotional situations and
emotions that could have been engaged
the episode did not make me cry at all
which is
unusual from my perspective and the way
that i understand my own emotions and my
own
emotional responses to things i don't
think this episode was designed to pull
up my heartstrings it was designed for
me to see
how the structure and status of
characters is changing
and that was the true intention the
episode wasn't constructed for tears it
was constructed for thought
we didn't go through enough of the
emotional turmoil to feel the way
gon and kilwa or cult did but we did go
through enough in the last episode to
meet them
at the right place emotionally in the
aftermath
i'm actually very happy we didn't have
to watch the failure in fact is this the
first time there's been a major failure
there was another during the hunter exam
kill was i wonder whether we'll see
flashbacks of kilwa's experience the way
we did last time or if that'll be the
end of it the construction of the series
is
really quite interesting in this way
despite the show being very action to
drive change it's been very reactive
overall and focused on the idea of
supporting others this episode leaned
strongly into family friends and how we
decide what we
need and what we want neither god nor
killua could learn what they needed to
in the time they were given and so
now they must sit back and wait to learn
from others or give up
and leave i don't know whether they have
a choice i don't know whether kilauea
will have a choice but to leave it makes
sense
there had to be a time eventually where
the children would have to be
children they would have to experience
failure and setback and that's part of
the constructive narrative that
interests me because now we're in a
position where we know more than the
protagonists
know that they can't do anything to
change the outcome at present and where
we're actually by necessity shifting who
the protagonists are
we're being forced to question what
worth means in so many contexts
who is worthy of fighting ants who is
worth the king's energy how does one
prove they are worthy to a new organism
how does one prove they're worthy to
their friends how will kilwa
tell gon he's leaving and how will his
method of doing that affect god's
confidence in himself i imagine he'll
drop the frustrated tears and go to
anger because that's what he's done in
the past but it's really unclear as to
whether that will actually happen
the damn broke for gone he's believed in
his abilities up to now and his
inability to be flexible
is his downfall now that he's facing
this the way he can choose to come back
to it might be humility
or giving up and trying to fight in
another way or he can keep running into
a wall
i'm not sure what she'll choose but i
can't wait to see what she does because
seeing how people act in difficult
circumstances is generally the point of
media we want to see
people battle face consequences and
learn to be better we want to see our
heroes
win not that we know whether or not god
is a hero
just that we want to see the heroes win
whoever they are if we compare gone and
cult
cult green themed in artwork as well has
hair that's up but has big ol angel
wings
and he's another child in a difficult
situation who cares about his mother and
has taken the opposite path rather than
trying to fight his way through every
situation he's trying to negotiate with
the enemy to find a way to help those he
cares about
colt is the anti-gon really if gon's a
psychopath who needs to learn to feel
empathy
colt's the empath who needs to learn to
fight for what he believes in
surrendering himself and his colony to
protect the queen what does he think
will happen with the queen safe
yes it means the order reasserts itself
and the ants don't entirely take over
the world
which would be very easy to do in this
circumstance where they don't
fight back but would she be able to go
against her own biology to resist the
king
finally the king is born and he has his
hat
and his little jacket and he is his cell
like
at least one iteration of self they're
very certainly related him and frieza
like
if frieza and cell had a baby that would
be him
same energy as well all the other ants
are food and the book on the floor
and kindness and special breeding and
family are all dead now because the
king's there i wasn't surprised when
pito wouldn't help the queen their only
concern is the king and he's proven he
could quite easily kill them all in that
colony so
you know duh having watched colt going
to get help he knew
absolutely already exactly where colt
was going it's funny that colt knew
exactly where to go on that point where
the others were lazing i'd suggest they
were not hidden all that well
we have a revolution to perform without
our original protagonists
any of them and colt knew where the most
powerful of them that we've seen
we're hidden welp i'm excited to see
more of the story but i'm even more
excited to see how it's told because
it's a bit of a subversion of narrative
at this point and i like that
it's got a vibe of game of thrones but
without a great deal of the gratuity and
violence and character perspectives now
as i make my way through i'm seeing the
numbers and thinking i might be
just as disappointed by the ending so i
guess let's hope more episodes are in
the making by the time i finish this
series
i doubt it but we can dream right maybe
that's what makes the brain so tasty
speaking of tasty time for me to go eat
so that's it from me
if you enjoyed the deep dark insights i
provided into this
light fairground of horror feel free to
like subscribe
share do all the good stuff and i'll see
you next time